[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's josh dumel back on the program
got a new movie it's called buddy games
and uh it's a after a falling out six
lifelong friends reunite to play the
buddy games an
insane competition filled with the
absurd physical and mental challenges
now all bets are off as the determined
pals fight claw and party for the chance
to win
thousand dollars how did i do with that
voice over there josh
that was beautiful you know i almost
wish i i'd made a different creative
decision there
dan and had me voice it over
exactly i could do it i always want to
do
you know what dvd commentary but i
always wanted to do that uh
in a world and then that's how all these
uh movie
trailers start in a world yeah
you know those guys who do those make a
lot of money
that would be a good side hustle for you
yeah you could do it i'd like that
uh we spent the last four minutes prior
to coming on
uh googling who you're dating mclovin
who is josh dating right now
well i have a you know it's hard to keep
track of this but
audra molly mari
mari mari yeah is she from north dakota
she is from north dakota is she there
she's there now yes i was just there two
days ago
oh but she's not there at your place no
no no she's not she's
she's actually in fargo okay but you
couldn't date somebody from south dakota
could you
well i i could date somebody from
anywhere but i choose to date her
well i know but but you're from north
dakota would you date somebody from
south dakota
that would be weird no no i don't know
do you have something against south
dakota i have nothing i have nothing
against south dakota
you know she's actually got a place
she's her family has a
leg cabin like less than an hour from
mine out there and i didn't know that
when i first met her was sort of a
a chance uh you know one of those
lucky little circumstances but not
wedding bells we're just we're dating
dan really what
i i i'm gonna plug the movie but i i
gotta
get a little gossip in here i gotta make
entertainment tonight come on
she she she is a keeper i'll i'll put it
down okay she's definitely a keeper
uh how's axel doing he's doing great
he's he's still asleep we went to bed a
little late last night i was up
i was i was gone all day yesterday to
impress for this movie and
he was uh he wanted some daddy time so
we we spent
uh uh we watched the hotel for dogs last
night
you know we stayed up a little past his
bedtime so he's still sleeping no school
this week
does he know what you do for a living
sure
he hasn't seen this movie though he
probably won't for another 10 years
all right uh you got some big stars in
here you got olivia munn
you got kevin dillon nick schwartzen dax
shepard
pretty good uh pretty good list there
now do you have to go recruit him
oh yeah yeah that was that was a whole
horse trade right there i had to get
because as you know you have to get
certain people with a certain
what they call q number uh which which
means i have a certain international
value and
dax and olivia had enough to sort of get
me greenlit for this movie so i went to
olivia and i said hey olivia
um dax is in if you wanna if you wanna
join i went to dax and said hey
so i had to pull i had to pull every
trick in the book to get this thing
right
but but the q rating explain that though
is that how movies are made or
some movies that may not get made they
get made because of
somebody's q rating who comes in yes
i mean they they basically i really
don't agree with this whole
formula they go by because i don't think
you know what
you know what somebody's curating in
germany and somebody's curating in korea
how that helps make a better movie i'd
rather get the right two people for the
movie
than you know depend on something
foreign but they what they do is they
have they can then pre-sell
all the money it's sort of like hedging
their bet before they even finance the
movie
uh we're talking to josh duhamel the uh
movie is called
buddy games when's it uh is it released
this
the thanksgiving weekend today oh today
yeah oh good yeah so we got
we got a great release we're on uh this
is a great this is the best weekend we
could have asked for
honestly yeah um 400 screens right now
which is good considering you know
what we're what we're in the middle of
uh so yeah it's it's um
you know as you know this has been a
long time coming this has been something
i've had to
you know push and pull and drag and kick
uh for for years to get it done and it's
been
it's i just can't wait for people to see
it now is it is there a love scene
with you um yes there is a love scene
it's really romantic you should check it
out well give me a little bit more than
that
is there a woman involved all right so
it's me and olivia and we're
at my parents place on a sunday morning
for brunch and she decides to spice
things up a little bit so she
she you know sort of stops me in the
bathroom as i'm washing my hands and it
sort of happens right there so yeah it's
not the most romantic love that you've
ever seen
uh and the scene itself i'm sort of
looking at myself
there's a there's a picture of myself as
a child as i'm
doing it and i have to stop because it's
too uncomfortable i feel like i'm
staring my
childhood self is staring at me
but are they always awkward when you do
love scenes
yeah i mean yeah they're not they're not
nearly as fun as they might look on
screen because you know you've got a
bunch of hairy camera dudes around and
you know your sound guys and
you know those grips and gaffers all
around so it's it's never as
sort of sensual as it might appear on on
screen it's pretty uncomfortable
actually
well i was in uh a sandler movie blended
and i had to kiss a woman
and i just met her wendy
covey mcclendon i think from the
goldbergs
oh yeah yeah yeah so sandler says
it's not in the script and then sandler
goes uh danny
i think you need to kiss wendy and
i mean i didn't i didn't know her and
next thing i know you know
sandler goes okay action and then i'm
kissing wendy covey mclendon
and i go how awkward is this but it's
not like that with you guys like you
know olivia munn don't you
well yes i do know olivia but you know
sometimes that's the way it is that
awkward because
i've done things where you know that you
as you know they shoot these things out
of order
and i haven't seen where i just met the
girl five minutes earlier and we have to
do like the love scene first
first day of the first you know of
shooting so
it's it's it's it's not the worst but
it's not it's just
truly part of the job uh wendy mcclendon
covey fritzy is telling me i had it in
reverse order so wendy mcclendon covey
very talented
woman from the goldbergs uh how would
you uh assess your vikings
well we are uh you know i just feel like
the vikes
this year for whatever reason we got off
to a really slow start
um won what two games in a row almost
three games in a row
and then lose to the cowboys last week
so i don't
it's i don't feel like this is probably
our year i
i i never count them out but i don't
know
until we get that quarterback that i
feel like can
put us over the top i don't i don't
think it's going to be any different
than any of yours past
oh so you're off the kirk cousins
bandwagon i have been
for a couple years now you have i
remember talking to josh when he left
the stadium after that was a playoff
game right a couple years ago
was that that was the oh that was in
that was in minnesota
after walsh missed that 24-yard field
goal the seattle game
yes oh my god oh god it's like it's like
there's a new way they find a new way to
break your heart every year
and then he calls and then i i know that
he just lost in dramatic fashion
and you know just like i miss that hurt
as a fan i don't have that because i
don't root for anybody i root for a
story line but
to have the high when it's really high
but also that pain
the reason why it hurts so much is you
care so much yeah
and you know russell wilson just has our
number he's been doing this
now for a few years he did it again this
year i don't know if you remember the
game
was a game like three or game four
dude just has the ability to take a team
back and that's that to me is what the
vikings are missing is that quarterback
who can
you know that if there's two minutes
left your team still has a shot
you know whether it's aaron rodgers or
you know brady although he didn't play
great last night
um you know bro guys like russell wilson
you just know that those guys are going
to give you a shot
but does it hurt knowing that green bay
still has aaron rodgers
a little bit yeah yeah they've had
they've had a
top quarterback now for 20 some years
haven't they
now you didn't bring up rogers to olivia
munn did you
um no why would i wait didn't she date
she dated aaron rodgers
you asked me if i whispered that in her
ear no i was just curious
if if it came because you're a viking
fan she dated aaron rodgers
i didn't know if that would come up in
conversation break the ice a little bit
yeah we talked about i mean i love i i
love aaron i think that he's you know
he's
truly one of the greatest arm talents
i've ever seen so
as a as a football fan i wanted to pick
her brain about him so
you know what was he like what did she
look like
i didn't ask her that i didn't think so
uh
the movie with uh you got kevin dillon
in here too from entourage jack shepherd
olivia munn and uh nick schwartzen
schwarty's great
he's crazy yeah he's he's he's uh
he's crazy all right but he's fantastic
in this movie
uh he was a big he was he was the first
guy on board when we first wrote it
and you know it's it's this is
i'm truly excited for people to see it
because it we've shown it now
in a few theaters and it absolutely
kills
it's it's it's extreme though dan i'm
going to warn you it's a it's
we pushed the envelope i you know my
favorite movies are movies like you know
the hangover and old school and dumb and
dumber
so i wanted to do something that sort of
pushes the envelope like those like
phillips and
fairly brothers those those directors do
and
you know it works and i'm excited for
i'm excited for people to see this thing
after all these years yeah it's been a
while
you've been talking about this for yeah
five years
yeah so it's i mean that's just that's
because of a certain
there's a few there's a few reasons for
that it was uh we ended up
um well i won't get into the legal stuff
but we
uh control the movie now and you know
with cove and everything else we had
we had to push it back to now but
ultimately we couldn't have asked for a
better date
i mean i'm really excited about this
weekend and um
you know it's the perfect thanksgiving
move
it sounds like it yeah fun for the
entire family
uh happy thanksgiving and uh i think
either you're ready to blow a kiss to me
or your screen just froze up
uh but uh say good uh say hello to uh
axel and uh
thank you josh that says yeah
you froze on me all right man
happy are thanksgiving going to be at
the 18t
this year i don't know we're trying to
figure that out i don't know
i don't know if i'm uh ready to travel
with the entire uh group here
well i'd sure love to see you there man
well it would be great and uh we would
love to go but uh
i'm not quite sure but uh have a great
thanksgiving great to talk to you good
luck with the movie
all right brother thanks for having me
that's josh dumel he's actor writer
producer director and the movie is
buddy games